good afternoon everyone
all right um welcome everyone
to our meeting this afternoon just a
reminder to you all that we are
on live stream um sarah has also
advised me that we're still on um one
microphone
per person but there is a
official request gone to iit to have it
resolved
so hopefully for future meetings it'll
be sorted
all right so we come to business so the
first is apologies we have new apologies
for this afternoon
any conflicts of interest
so we come to item three the
confirmation of minutes um
3.1 so there's a recommendation
moved by council atkinson seconded by
council duty any discussion
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear that carriage
so we come to reports item 5 vs 5.1
local government funding agency that's
a report in the name of mr millwood
welcome to our table jeff
pages 15 to 82 everyone uh good
afternoon mr mayor and councillors
this report uh has two things one to
increase the uh covenants for the
uh rates revenue or revenue to
uh debt and sorry debt to revenue and
the other one is to
provide delegations to the two people
noted in the report
to vote on our behalf i'll be present on
zoom
but this provides surety that the vote
is taken
i thought the rest of the report has
been read
thanks mr millwood any questions of mr
millwood
no someone prepared to move the
recommendation
how's the barnett seconded by council
award councilman do you wish to speak
just quickly it's obvious that in
extraordinary times there needs to be
some extra measures taken
and thankfully it doesn't look like our
council's in that top tier that's
actually needs this measure but it does
seem a sensible move
i'm very comfortable with the report
thank you very much
any further speakers write reply
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried thank you
mr millwood
next is item 5.2 which is the
development contribution schedule uh
kelly lavelli
kelly
thank you mr mayor so this report is to
adopt the 2021 development contributions
there were just a few changes and there
that were summarized in the report as a
result of annual planned deliberations
but the remainder of the development
contributions schedule
remains the same from consultation so
that i'll
take any questions
any questions
counsel about it just just one from me
there kelly the
the drainage contributions for some
areas seem to be
nil is that being reviewed in the future
with with
in light of the fact that there are some
areas there that do have significant
drainage issues
um so my best understanding to
um to answer your question is that most
of the drainage related issues that
occur in existing areas are not
attributable to
growth so it'd only be the growth
related projects that show up
within the development contribution
schedules and
we for most of the urban areas we
have drainage projects
catering for that specific development
in that development contribution area
which would be separate from
from this scheme
any further questions we have a
recommendation
someone prepared to move
oh i'll move it um seconded by
councillor brian i have nothing to add i
think it's a good report thank you kelly
and happy to support it any further
any further contributions i'll put the
recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary
to clear that carried thanks kelly
so we come to um item 5.3
see i think you must
are you leading that cheer for as is
paul coming up to present that paper
this carryovers
pages 108 to 118.
uh this report in front of you basically
puts
together all of the items that were
carried over in the
reports that were invited to the council
during the deliberations
uh and it um it's a good way of bringing
everything together so that
nothing has been missed uh
and basically i'll just take the report
as being read happy to take any other
questions
but it basically puts in the context uh
what's happened from
the current capital works program any
carryovers that have been taken into
consideration
uh the new capital works program that
was provided in the 2021 year
any considerations of capital works that
have been pushed out
and the resulting figure that we're now
working with for
thanks jeff any questions
do we have a recommendation someone
prepared to move
don't don't put your hands up at once
council mailings some of its second
council councilmanians which do you wish
to speak
casabana any further speakers
put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried uh the
next is item 5.4
which is the adoption of the annual plan
and that's mr palmer 119-121
thank you mr mayor clearly this is the
report that draws together all of the
work that has been done
over the last
near enough to 12 months in some cases
about preparing a draft annual plan
going through a consultation process
uh receiving submissions back on that
and forming a view and in the middle of
that of course we've had covert which
has added the dimension um which we've
not seen before i think
it was somewhat given the timing of
covert i think it was
good that we had actually got our
process underway and out for public
engagement before covert in some ways
that
and we extended the timelines which
enabled people to be able to comment we
got
relatively few comments commentators
on our annual plan although there were
a high number of submission points from
each
submitter which was good we've
landed in a position that the council's
considered
through its consideration and
deliberation on submissions
and now is in the place to formally
adopt its annual plan and that's an
important
step as we can't actually set rates
until we've
adopted an annual plan and we're
adopting ours before 30 june which is
what the statute requires i'd note that
there are a number of other councils who
have already signaled that they won't
meet that time
frame because they were either late
putting their draft annual plan out
or have needed further extension to deal
with the
issues associated with covert pandemic
so
i uh in a separate attachment
is the draft annual plan document
um you may have had a chance to have a
look at that
um that well
that draws together all of the key
threads
there's a resolution or recommendation
that
jeff and i be authorised to make any
further minor editorial
changes that occur before it's finally
published
i'm not anticipating any but if there
are that authority
is sought other than that i'm happy to
answer any questions you may have
thank you
thanks germany questions
well i'm i'm going to move this report
yeah
and seconded so i'm going to move the
recommendation and seconded by
council atkinson i just firstly want to
say that
um thank you to the staff who've done an
exceptional amount of work to get us to
this position
as we all know we went out in the early
part of the ship this year we
uh went out with a four per cent
suggested increase and that's what we
went as the basis of our consultation
and obviously clearly since
covert 19 we indicated to our community
that we would look to
revise that and that's what we've done
and getting to the position of 1.5
as the projected average increase has
been
it's been a large amount of work to get
us to this point
as councillors we've had a lot of um uh
meetings via zoom through the um
lockdown period so we were well briefed
as we went into the
uh our hearing process and the message
we got from
a range of the submitters was that they
did want us to
get the right rates to a level as low as
is possible
i'm really pleased we didn't go out with
the position as others
were tempted to to indicate they get to
zero because
there's consequences in getting to zero
as other councils have
have found and not being able to deliver
on that
it's disappointing to communities when
you indicate that so i'm pleased that
what we did was indicate that we'd get
to a position
that we would uh get to as low as
possible and that's what we've done in
this exercise
um just on in terms of staff
particularly i'd like to acknowledge our
ceo
also our finance managers all the senior
managers
and all the other staff that have
contributed
reviewing all our budgets getting to us
to this point as well as our governance
team
of sarah and all the staff that are
around that have supported us
over that period of time thank you it's
been a difficult period because trying
to set up through zooms hasn't
exactly been entirely easy but we've
managed that exercise i think as well as
can and i
appreciate the patience and perseverance
of our staff through that time it's been
really great lastly the
the real work starts very soon again
um as we're preparing for our long-term
plan
and in the next year as we're
preparing for our 10-year plan we've got
a lot of work to do
um to on our program on the go forward
from there as we indicated through our
annual plan as we've deferred some
projects
where we'll end up and how we manage
that program over the next 10 years is
going to require a lot of discipline and
a lot of work so
look forward to working with you all in
the development of our long term plan in
the next
year council atkinson
thank you mr mia i just want to pick up
where you left off on the 10-year plan i
normally probably wouldn't have been too
happy with the uh
with deferring projects as we we have
and that creates a bow wave and and
percentages as you move into
the later years however some of the luck
that has come out of having covert i
suppose is the fact that
next year for everybody is a 10-year
plan which means
you can take everything and review the
lot and have a look at how you're going
to get that across to your new period
and get you your rises or not
into the right percentages or
into the right area that they should be
have
not had that coming up um next year
i possibly would have a different view
on cutting right back
to 1.5 percent because as i say that
bowel wave
that comes after that and the
percentages that you have to do as many
councils are actually experiencing this
year just before covert and
now finding out that um doing what they
promised the zero percent
actually isn't going to work for them
you know i think it's very responsible
what's happened here and i think that
it's actually something that
um each one of us can thank our staff
for to getting us this point there are
cuts in there
there are not only cuts there are
deferrals but as i say for the next 10
years
um that will be sorry for next year that
will be the time
to be sorting out where we're going what
we're doing and timely
putting things in and hopefully
addressing
the best we can the carry-overs that
we've had
in the past and you've heard me talk
about that
many times around this table recently
and i'm dead serious about that i want
to see that
into realistic programs so that we
aren't
asking for huge expectations of our
staff to deliver on things that
we want and put the pressure on we want
to make sure that it's realistic in my
view
and our mirror is absolutely right that
we need to have the expectations going
into this annual plan
that will deliver something that we can
do over the next 10 years
so i look forward to those discussions
again thank you to the staff there has
been
a hell of a lot of work considering you
didn't have access to this building
during the major time that we were doing
this so
well done and i look forward to the
response
of the community
yeah while i agree with um council x and
there's a bow wave coming
um i don't can't really support this
because
i don't think we did enough by gaining a
bit more efficiencies out of the council
um smoothing our situation across
affects the following years coming and i
think with this covert thing that the
following years coming is going to be
the um
the real challenge for this council
as per what council atkins said we've
got an advantage here because we can
try to trim things and sort things out
in the next
10 year plan hopefully we'll be able to
do that and the staff will work hard on
it but i think we really got to
start looking at a few more efficiencies
in this council
to get things back on track and be one
of the best little councils in
new zealand
yes i'm fully supportive of this annual
plan and i would note
that the normal cpi for local government
costs
sits around two to three percent and has
done so for many years
so at a 1.5 percent rate increase
we're actually below local government
cpi which means we have
had to cut some levels of service across
the board
so to have done any more than that i
think
the public would have not been happy
with the types of levels of service we
would have had to cut
so i'm comfortable where we sit i think
we've listened to the
feedback from our community about
cutting costs and
we know we had to ease the burden of in
this financial year
while we figure out what's actually
going to happen
i see this as a cautious wait and see
budget
and we really don't know the full impact
of covert 19 on new zealand's economy
and on the global economy
and how that will affect us at the local
area we don't know
what funding will come from government
it seems to be changing daily
and changes in our work programs may be
coming
with the 51 that we're reliant on from
places like
nzta we then have to be agile enough to
shift our budget to meet
funding available to get the best
benefit for our ratepayers
so i think we've taken a cautious
approach and we've pushed out a lot of
projects to review
for this year but i do urge caution for
the long-term plan 10-year plan
we may have to delay projects further
we may have to review our level of
service
district-wide affordability is probably
going to be the top issue
for the next two to five years under the
current economic
projections that we've seen so i urge
you that
going forward we need to make sure we
bring the community with us
we keep them well informed and we ask
them
why why did why we want to do this why
do we need to do this
to make sure that everyone in our
community is looked after
thank you mr mayor when we initially
went out for consultation we were
looking
and we thought we were doing well at
four percent we've now come in at
the mythical average of 1.5 percent
um i'm pleased to support this
recommendation
i feel the staff and us as a council
have done quite a big job the
the reduction does not come without
costs there are some things that will be
deferred
however we've balanced the community
expectation
which the media went out and um
drummed up zero percent everywhere i
think that
is pretty unrealistic and not a viable
option for a
business going forward
at 1.5 we've balanced
what we would have liked to have been
doing with what the community expects of
us
um we've certainly kicked some cans down
the road
so 21 22 is going to be a challenging
year
for us together with the ltp
the effect of covert 19 as councillor
barnett has indicated as not
yet fully known i don't think the
effects
on our local economy have
all come home to roost yet
the effects are being suppressed by wage
subsidies and other measures
so we're going into an area of the
unknown really
but i think we've acted with our
community's well-being at heart
and uh certainly the recovery plan and
other things
i think the council has actually
handled this very well and we're in
quite a good space
fortunately we're in a reasonably strong
position prior to covet 19
and that's enabled us to um weather the
storm to a certain degree
so i i'm very pleased to support the
recommendation
um i regard 21
22 with some trepidation but we'll cross
that bridge when we get
to it thank you
thank you um i have to congratulate
staff on amazing
work that they've done keeping the rates
the the the keeping the um
all the projects down and being
efficient with their
with their operations i think they do an
amazing job
and in my opinion i have to say i think
they are
very efficient um they do have to
do amazing work to just dot all the eyes
and across the t's
to comply with transparency
but i also like to take this opportunity
to say that you know
there is a big opportunity in the next
two or three years with recovery and
with the way
that we're positioned so that we can
look after jobs in the district
we do have a lot of growth projects that
require
to be done and we mustn't put those
aside we must
continue to do those especially at the
moment when interest rates are so low
so i'm very optimistic that we can
provide jobs for our people by growth
projects that we need to do going
forward in the next 10 years and
i'll be looking forward to promoting
those thank you
thank you further speakers
just in right of reply just just to
reiterate some main points
i'm very proud of what we've all
achieved through this process
and there is this the team of staff and
the elected members
the rates what we've indicated to be the
rates
average rates increase as i've moved
around has been very well received by
the community that have certainly
expressed
and i've seen them just how grateful
they are that we've made the effort we
have to get it to where it is so
there will be parts of our community
that of course would like to have seen
it lower but
they have certainly generally indicated
to me that they are very pleased with
where we've got to in that space
council williams i look forward to your
ideas on efficiencies as we
come into our long-term plan i'm
welcoming those
got a very open mind to to see what
other opportunities we've got so look
forward to your ideas as we come into
the long-term plan
um council bond that's absolutely right
as we
indicate to our community the years
ahead will be around affordability and
how we manage that and as we've all
mentioned the challenge will be in the
long term plan as i indicated as other
other speakers have as well we've got a
a lot of work to do
to balance all the priorities we have
and to make sure that that expenditure
is minimised as best as we can to
present an affordable position to our
community
just one thing i'd like to say in
closing is
i do hope we pass this budget
unanimously i can't can't make you do
that
but i hope we do because i think it
sends a message to our community
and to our staff who've put a lot of
work into it that we are
appreciative of all the work that's been
done to get us to this point
with that i urge you to support the
recommendation
so i'll put that now all those in favor
please say aye
contrary i declare that carried
okay all right
we come to item 5.5
pages one two two two one three four
lee welcome to the table
thank you um good afternoon
the race resolution is a requirement
under the rating act
and we need to
carry it to set the rates for the new
year
any questions
it's an excellent summary lee very good
so um
any questions of colleagues
right so got an indication of him amoeba
hold on just check there's any other
quick no questions
moved by council atkinson seconded by
council award
council atkinson
very quickly thank you lee
do you wish to say anything counselor
any further speakers write a reply
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear they're carried thank
you
okay well that's that brings us to the
um to
item six i have no questions there's no
urgent general business that i've been
made aware of so just to advise our next
meeting is on tuesday the 7th of july at
1 o'clock
thank you everyone for your attendance
and just wouldn't mind if councillors
could remain
just a just a couple of items to brief
you on